as you know two suicide bombers assessed
to have been isis fighters
detonated in the vicinity of the abbey
gate at hamad karzai international
airport and in the vicinity of the
barren hotel which is immediately
adjacent
the attack on the abbey gate was
followed by a number of isis gunmen who
opened fire on civilians and military
forces
at this time we know that 12 u.s service
members have been killed in the attack
and 15 more service members have been
injured a number of afghan civilians
were also killed and injured in the
attack we are treating some of them
aboard hkia many other afghan civilians
have been taken out to hospitals in town
we're still working to calculate the
total losses we just don't know it uh
what that is right now their loss weighs
heavily on us all and i'll talk a little
bit more about that as we go through my
prepared remarks
we continue to focus on the protection
of our forces and the evacuees as the
evacuation continues
let me be clear while we're saddened by
the loss of life both u.s and afghan
will continue to execute the mission our
mission is to evacuate u.s citizens
third country nationals special
immigrant visa holders u.s embassy staff
and afghans at risk
despite this attack we are continuing
the mission the evacuation at best speed
and as of today we have approximately 5
000 evacuees on the ramp at hkya
awaiting airlift
since august the 14th we've evacuated
more than 104 000 civilians from the
from hkia
over 66 000 by the united states and
over 37 000 by our allies and partners
and that includes bringing out about 5
000 americans
as the secretary of state said yesterday
we believe that there are about a
thousand probably a little more than a
thousand american citizens left in
afghanistan at this point
we're doing everything we can in concert
with our department of state partners to
reach out to them and to help them lead
if they want to leave and remember not
everybody wants to leave
yesterday we brought in over 500
american citizens
it would be difficult to overestimate
the number of unusual challenges and
competing demands that our forces on the
ground have faced
the threat to our forces particularly
from isis k is very real as we have seen
today
i would also like to express the sense
of profound pride i have in the creative
determined and professional way that our
forces have overcome those challenges
and to deliver the
results that we talked about in my
opening portion of the remarks the
number of people that we've been able to
extract from afghanistan
it would also be remiss of me not to
mention the tremendous contributions of
our many coalition partners and they
stood with us on the ground at age kaya
and also the interagency and
international partners who supported the
evacuation the many soldiers sailors
airmen marines and coast guardsmen who
supported this operation downrange
across the central command the european
command and the northern command areas
of responsibility
moreover this evacuation could simply
not have been done without the amazing
flexibility of u.s transportation
command in the airlift provided by the
united states air force
no other military in the world has
anything like it i'd also like to thank
the host nations that have generously
provided access to their facilities for
the processing the care and the feeding
of our evacuees
i also need to acknowledge the temporary
suffering that some of our evacuees have
had to endure
please know that we continue to execute
our number one mission which is to get
as many american citizens and other
evacuees as possible out of afghanistan
we also continue to expand the capacity
at our intermediate facilities to ensure
safe sanitary and humane conditions for
our evacuees
while continuing to look for ultimate
ways to expedite their processing and
ultimate transfer to the united states
or other destinations
i'd like to close out my remarks today
by just taking a moment to describe the
heroism that our marines soldiers and
sailors are exhibiting as they screen
the people who are coming onto the
airfield
this is close up work
the breadth of the person you are
searching is upon you
while we have overwatch in place we
still have to touch the close of the
person that's coming in
i think you all can appreciate the
courage and the dedication that is
necessary to do this job
and to do it time after time
please remember that we have screened
over 104 000 people
finally i'd like to offer my profound
condolences to the families of our
service men and women and afghan
civilians who lost their lives today
we have put more than 5 000 u.s service
members at risk to save as many
civilians as we can
it's a noble mission and today we have
seen firsthand how dangerous that
mission is
isis will not deter us from
accomplishing the mission i can assure
you of that
all americans can and should be proud of
the men and women of the armed forces
who are facing these dangers head-on
with their international partners
and all our other friends that are with
us
and we appreciate your thoughts and
prayers for all our service members who
are carrying on this mission today